I've never had a lunchable I wanted them
because he had like cool commercials I
always thought they look like play-doh
cracker stackers this looks fun a lot of
fat that's cool oh it comes with a drink
the meat is like watery do I like touch
it I have this block of sweaty cheese
I'm touching a dog's tongue half of this
package is a Reese's Cup after the
Reese's on top I would eat the effect at
a field trip to the zoo or something
this is the one that I always saw when I
was a kid the pizza one I just love how
future this is the kind of food that
astronauts eat ah this doesn't appeal to
me he's the other crush that was kind of
fun a tiny bit of math floral arms up a
giant nipple edible I actually feel good
about this one this would definitely
save you from a bully if you gave it to
him pancakes
they make breakfast there's something
that some people might refer to as bacon
I wonder how long it's been in this box
upsettingly skooshy very weird just like
a sponge man oh my god that was really
good this is fantastic
but other people like this did anyone
like this is childhood dream still like
have tiny pancakes that you dip and then
you make a mess and get all of your
fingers and then you touched up barbeque
chicken
shake ups rip it pour it seal and shake
it the last thing I want to do is put
barbecue sauce on this shake it up and
then eat it
it's like watery and soggy but I'm so
distracted by this seasoning
kids love chicken nuggets I don't like
it chicken nuggets if you told a robot I
would like you to put together a
barbecue chicken finger this is what
that robot would give you you're gonna
go tell my parents that I finally had
Lunchables
I'm just gonna eat a lot of salad I
don't think that this qualifies
is a lunch I'm not sure that it
qualifies as food you're a really busy
parent with like a high-powered job
Lunchables are the way to go